So, now I'm done with the mastectomy and the reconstructive surgeries.
I want to focus on making sure that there's no reoccurrence.
In what order do I complete these?
Order a complete wellness panel, order cheek swab testing, do a one-on-one consult with you.
I would do it in probably the stack order that you wrote that.
I would get this going right away.
Order this, get this blood test done.
We tell you you can send in the cheek swab sample right away.
And then after we do the cheek swab testing, unless there's things that you want to discuss
before we tested, put a new protocol together for you, you could wait and tell you get
that protocol back from me and then schedule the one-on-one.
So it really has to do with the purpose of this one-on-one if you want to talk about it
before.
Some people are like, I really want to change my whole protocol, cut my back or maybe
have financial concerns or maybe they just want to change your life.
They don't want to take as many supplements anymore or whatever it is that I can be a little
bit more choosy.
But of course you could write that on any specifics on your cheek swab testing form, or we
didn't know that too.
And then wait until you get that back and tell you might formulate some more questions to
do on one-on-one consult.
And remember, you could just schedule that yourself right on that page on the member site
or on our self-scheduling page on our regular website as well.